moi
bon
un démon probablement que ce raymond
radiguet mort à 20 ans en 1923 au terme
d'une existence déjà follement rempli
d'amitié forte cocteau picasso aragon
satie de soirée et de nuit de rêve et
d'oeuvres étrangement forte comme ce
diable au corps qui ornent la nouvelle
collection de livres à 10 francs publié
par j'ai lu sous le titre librio ce ne
sont pas des livres de poche
colette troyat kafka mais aussi
shakespeare et stephen king
dans le même temps stock publie les
oeuvres complètes de raymond radiguet
dont on ne connaissait il faut le
reconnaître que les romands davantage
que son théâtre ou que ses poèmes sa
prose critique vaut le détour
on conçoit les mouvements divers comme
on dit à la chambre qu'a provoquée le
diable au corps je vais encourir bien
des reproches mais qu'y puis-je averti
dès la première ligne
l'auteur de ce récit détachée d'un
adultère en temps de guerre on reste
plus de trente ans après sa parution le
film quand tu iras claude autant lara et
qu'interprétait gérard philipe et
micheline presle ne causa pas moins
d'émotion